لنا أوسكار سبيتز من حفلة تنكرية البار
الاستفادة من الفيلم ، من الواضح أنني هنا
فيلم هوالي المليون اللعين هل هو
استغرق ثانية ومليون سأفعل
الفضاء كان سيأخذني على r
تعليق allium udovik pro سعيد للزيارة
هذا الموضوع يأكل قناعا
لقد ماتت من قبل قرن روبوفوريكس الذي كنت عليه
سائق دبابة t-34 لنا
الثلاثين الشهيرة التي مرت
الحرب كلها
في ربيع السنة الخامسة والأربعين في القطاع
جارح
جيش دبابات الحرس الثالث لدينا
كان هناك تركيز كبير
أصبح قيادة معسكر أوشفيتز
ومعلوم أن هذا المخيم يقترب
يريدون تدمير قواتنا بالكامل
لقد أمرنا بالرد على الدبابات
بأقصى سرعة لهذا المعسكر و
تحرك واقتربنا منه محاطين
في كل مكان عندما مشيت تحت
على خزان الوقود الخاص بك كبوابة
أعلاه كان مكتوبا
كان ماشت فري خارج البوابة فارغًا
ولم يكن هناك أحد محمي وسيكون كل شيء فيه
وثكنات مغلقة بالخارج
أعدهم الألمان للتدمير و
من بين أمور أخرى ، المواد القابلة للاحتراق
التي أعدوها للندم
معسكر
أخذ الضابط سياراتهم و
drapanuli والحراس الخاصين القيت
التعسف
وهؤلاء هم هؤلاء الحراس
وقعنا في أسرهم
وكان من بينهم بولنديون وحتى أوكرانيون
عندما ذهب معهم المشاة من العالم السادس
هذا هو الكشافة لدينا مرتبة
حسب الجنسية حسب الدولة
كان هناك خبز الزنجبيل من جميع أنحاء أوروبا
مجردة وكانوا بينهم و
وكان المدنيون والنساء والأطفال بشرًا
كانوا هزالين لدرجة أنهم
بالكاد تحركوا عندما خرجوا وشر
أو إلى البوابة
عقد بعضهم البعض والبعض الآخر لم يفعل ذلك
يمكن حتى
الذهاب والزحف ، بالطبع نحن نتفهم ذلك
أنقذنا
هؤلاء الناس الذين يمكن أن يكونوا
دمرت في لحظة وأعطاهم
رابط التعلق بجدي قوي جدا
بالتأكيد أثرت في حياتي
أقول رده أولاً
تعلمت ما هو الشرف ما هو الكبرياء
هذه هي المشاعر والصفات
شخص ببساطة ليس في أي مكان يذهبون إليه
سوف يأتون فمن الضروري أن يغرس أنا أبدا
أضع نفسي أعلى من أي شخص آخر
هذا هو الحال والتفاهم يتعاطف
الناس الذين قد لا يملكون كل شيء
متطورة في هذه الحياة و
فعلا فخورون بوطنهم لذلك
أنني روسي كنت سعيدًا جدًا إذا
لم يعد الأشخاص الآخرون يعرفون ما هو عليه
المجاعة والحرب أنا وأنا أتحدث باسم الروس
الروس لا يريدون الحصول عليه
[موسيقى]